Now that we understand a little bit
about how the material we are creating is going to function,
let's go ahead and start creating that material.
Now to do this, we're first gonna have to make
a brand new material inside of our content browser.
And then when we open that material up,
we're gonna add two texture samples
and we're gonna convert these to texture parameters,
one called BC Dirt and the other called BC Grass.
And the reason that we're creating these
as texture parameters is to make it easier
for us to adjust the landscapes textures
once the landscape has been created and turned into an instant.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor now.
With the editor open, I'm gonna hit Control Space
and I'm just gonna come here
and I'm going to right click, go to my material
and just do MAT underscore landscape.
And then we're gonna double click on this to open it up.
Now the texture samples that we use
are not really that important
because remember, we're gonna make these into parameters.
So let's go ahead and just pull in two textures.
Now we can do this a number of different ways.
The way that I like to do it is hold down the T key
on the keyboard and click
and that's gonna add a texture sample.
Now, unfortunately, this just adds this.
We do need to add some type of texture inside of here.
The other way that we can do this
is if we hit Control Space
and we come over here to say like surfaces,
I'm gonna go up here to let my dried grass
and I just grabbed this texture and pull it in like so.
It's also going to pull that texture in.
So I'm gonna actually just delete this one
and we're gonna right click on this for the time being.
I'm gonna go convert to parameter
and we're gonna call this one BC for base color
underscore grass.
And then I'm gonna hit Control Space
and we're gonna go to,
we'll go to this rocky ground right here
and we'll grab this texture sampler.
We'll pull that in and then we're gonna right click
and go convert to parameter BC underscore dirt.
All right, so next what we're going to do
is we are going to create our slope setup.
Now this involves the following nodes.
We have a slope angle.
The slope angle allows us to control the angle
at which this interaction is going to happen.
So generally we want this to happen
from the top to the bottom,
but there could be an instance
where maybe we want some action
from the left side or the right side.
So we're gonna add this in there
just in case we wanna mess around
with these values a little bit and make some adjustments.
We then have the slope fall off power
and the slope contrast.
Now what these two nodes allow us to do
is control the way our two textures
are going to be mixed.
The slope fall off power is gonna control
kind of the fall off between texture A and texture B
and the contrast is going to increase
or decrease the sharpness of that.
Finally, all of these nodes are gonna be plugged
into our slope mask, which is a material function
that allows us to define the slope part A
and the slope part B.
So let's go ahead and set this up inside of our material.
So we're gonna pop over here to the material editor.
I'm just gonna pull back here a little bit
and we are going to first off,
we're gonna hold down the four key on the keyboard
and left click and that's gonna add
a four channel parameter node,
which we can then right click on
and convert to a parameter.
And we're gonna call this slope angle
and then the default value here
is going to be one in the blue.
All right, so next what we need to do
is we need to add some constant parameter nodes.
So I'm gonna hold down the one key and click once
and that's gonna add a constant parameter.
So again, holding down the one key on the keyboard
and then left clicking will add that constant parameter.
Then we're gonna click on this, right click on it
and convert to a parameter.
And we are gonna call this first one.
This should be slope fall off power.
And we're gonna give it a default value of one.
And then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna hit Control C
and then Control V, whoops, Control C, Control V.
That's gonna duplicate this node for us.
And we're gonna call this new node that we duplicated
slope contrast.
And we're gonna leave its value set to 1.0.
Next, what we need to do is we need to add
our slope mask.
Now, unfortunately, we can't add the slope mask
through a keyboard shortcut.
We do need to click inside of here
and then search for our slope.
And right here, we have a slope mask.
It's just showing up in two locations
so we can select either or.
So I'm gonna select this top one right here.
So there we go, there's our slope mask.
And what we're gonna do next is we are gonna connect
everything together like this.
So we're going to go ahead and set up our BC dirt
and our BC grass, and then we're gonna use a lerp.
And a lerp stands for linear interpolate.
And lerps are really a fantastic thing
inside of your materials as they allow you to mix
two inputs like our BC dirt and our BC grass by an alpha.
And this is really where things start to happen.
So with this setup on screen,
which we're gonna make in just a second,
this will already allow us to have some type
of interaction with our landscape.
So let's go ahead and set this up now.
So back over in the editor, we are going to,
first, we're gonna add our lerp parameter.
So to add a lerp, we can hold the L key down
on the keyboard and press, and that's gonna add our lerp.
So we're gonna connect the RGB or the RGB output
of our BC grass into the A input,
and then the RGB of our BC dirt into the B.
And now what we need to do is just set this up.
Now this is actually pretty easy to set up.
All we need to do is take the output of our slope angle
and plug that into here.
And then I wanna move these two parameters down like slow.
So, and we have our slope fall off power,
which is going to be right up here.
And then this cheap contrast is gonna go
in our slope contrast.
Once all of that has been completed,
all we need to do now is take this result
and plug it right here into our alpha,
and then take the output of our alpha
and plug it into our base color.
Now that we have that done,
we can actually see this kind of happening in action.
We can see there is our dirt
and then there is our grass.
So let's go ahead and apply and save this
so we can save our work.
Now I'm gonna move some things around here
because the next thing that I want to talk about
is the named reroute.
Now, as this material starts to grow in size,
it is gonna become very difficult to read
through the various wires that connect everything.
So we can add this new named reroute declaration node.
And this is really cool
because what this allows us to do
is it allows us to put blocks of shader code
off to the side.
And then instead of having to make a wire connection
across the entire graph,
we can pull these little named reroute declaration nodes
out, plug them into their respective inputs,
and that will make that connection with us
without us having to really worry too much
about the wire interaction.
So let's go ahead and pull one of these out
by coming over here to the editor,
and we're gonna right-click inside of here
and look for a named, and right there,
add a named reroute declaration node.
So we're gonna put this in here,
and we're gonna call this new one slope.
And let's take that.
So slope, there we go.
And then what we're gonna do
is I'm actually gonna hold down Alt and click right here,
which is gonna break our connection.
And we're gonna move this little bit of shader logic
just over here.
And then for these named reroutes to work,
what we do is we take this result
and we just plug it in right there like that.
Then we come over here,
and if we just click inside of the shader graph,
we look for this named reroutes, we grab the slope,
and then we plug this in like so.
So look, we have the exact same behavior
that we had before.
And if I just undo this, we can see here,
there is a little bit,
but it's kind of mixing it all together.
So it's just showing kind of both of them.
If we plug this back in,
you can see here it's got the rock and then the grass.
So let's go ahead and apply and save.
And this concept, and here's again,
an example of what we did, if you need to catch up,
we took our slope mask, we took our slope angle,
we put that into our fall off power
and our cheap contrast,
and then we added our named declaration for slope.
And then inside of our lerp,
we just looked for our named reroute
and we input that into our alpha.
Now this is really, really powerful
because we're gonna be doing this
for a lot of other things that we need to do.
For example, next up,
we are going to add some tiling,
but in order to do this for all of the different things
that we're gonna have in this,
we are going to make our tiling code off to the side,
like with our slope contrast,
and then we're gonna add a named reroute.
So let's go ahead and set this up now.
All right, so first off, we're gonna come over here
and we're gonna add a texture coordinate.
So there's our texture coordinate.
Then I'm gonna hold down the one key and click,
and that's gonna add a constant,
which we're gonna right click and convert to a parameter,
which we are going to call grass underscore tile.
We're gonna give this a default value of one.
Then what we're gonna do is I'm gonna hold down
the M key on the keyboard and click to add a multiply.
And then we're gonna connect like so.
Now, once we have these two connected,
we are going to look for a,
add a named reroute declaration node.
And we are gonna call this grass underscore tile.
Oh, and it looks like it didn't take the name again.
And we're gonna plug our output of our multiply
into our grass tile.
So let's just recap and give everybody a chance
to catch up.
Here is what we've been doing.
So there is our grass tile with our texture cord.
That's multiply.
Remember, we got that multiply by pressing M
on the keyboard and left clicking.
And then we added our named reroute declaration,
which we called grass tile.
Now, the next thing that we're going to do
is we're gonna duplicate this work,
but we're gonna call this new one dirt tile.
And then once we've created that dirt tile,
we're gonna plug in our grass tile
to match what we see on the screen in front of us.
So let's pop over to the editor now
and go ahead and take care of that.
So really easily, we can come up here
and we can right click and just duplicate this
and move it up.
And now we need to just change this from grass to dirt.
So we're gonna go D-I-R-T.
And then we're gonna change this one to D-I-R-T.
Oops, looks like it got rid of everything.
All right, so dirt tile, grass tile,
and then we just need to come over here
to our BC grass and our BC dirt
and input things respectively.
So we're gonna go named reroute, dirt tile,
and named reroute grass tile.
So let's take our grass tile, there we go.
And then our dirt tile, there we go.
All right, so let's go ahead and apply and save.
All right, so next what we need to do
is we need to set up this exact same logic,
but we need to do it for our roughness
and our normal maps.
So the easiest thing for us to do
is to actually duplicate what we have.
And really all we have to change
is just the names of the 2D textures parameters.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So I'm gonna pop back over here
and you're gonna see this is gonna be really,
really simple and fast.
So we're just gonna take all of this code
and I'm gonna hit control C
and then control V to paste that in there.
And then instead of BC grass,
this is gonna be our roughness.
So we're gonna call this our grass
and then we're gonna call this one our dirt.
All right, now we do need to change these texture sampler.
So what I'm gonna do here
is I'm gonna press this browse to asset
and we're gonna grab this dried grass 4K ORDP.
This is basically,
and I'll open this up so we can see it really quick.
So what this is a mass texture
that's storing different information in the red,
the green and the blue channels of our map here.
What we're interested in is the G and the B channels.
So the roughness is going to be inside of the G channel
and the B channel is gonna contain the displacement.
That's what these letters after the term means.
So the O is the occlusion or the ambient occlusion,
R is the roughness and D is the displacement.
So once we have this grass texture in here,
all we're gonna do is we're gonna come here
to our individual channel.
We're gonna grab the G right here and plug that in.
And then the same for our dirt.
We're going to find out where its mask is,
grab its mask, replace,
and then pull in from the G channel right there.
Then we're gonna plug this in to our roughness.
All right, so next when you just take all of this
and then hit control C, control V,
and we're going to change this now to N underscore grass
and then N underscore dirt.
And then we, again, we're gonna look for this
inside of the content browser,
select the normal map version of it
to make sure that we have a normal map inside of here.
And like so, and then once we've done that,
we are going to connect this to the normal input.
And one other thing, if yours looks like this,
I did forget, we need to take our RGB outputs here
and plug these back in like so.
And there we go.
Now we've got proper normals looking on our object here.
So let's apply and save.